my first year of grad school i found
myself in my bedroom eating lots of ben
jerry's watching some trashy tv and
maybe maybe listening to taylor swift
i had just gone through a breakup
so
for the longest time all i would do is
recall the memory of this person over
and over again wishing that i could get
rid of that gut-wrenching visceral blah
feeling
now as it turns out i'm a neuroscientist
so i knew that the memory of that person
in the awful emotional undertones that
color in that memory are largely
mediated by separate brain systems and
so i thought what if we could go into
the brain and edit out that nauseating
feeling but while keeping the memory of
that person intact and then i realized
maybe that's a little bit lofty for now
so what if we could start off by going
into the brain and just finding a single
memory to begin with
could we jump start that memory back to
life maybe even play with the contents
of that memory
all that said there is one person in the
entire world right now that i really
hope is not watching this talk so
so
there is a catch there is a catch
these ideas probably remind you of total
recall eternal sunshine of the spotless
mind or of inception but the movie stars
that we work with are the celebrities of
the lab
test mice
as neuroscientists we work in the lab
with mice trying to understand how
memory works and today we hope to
convince you that now we're actually
able to activate a memory in the brain
at the speed of light
to do this there's only two simple steps
to follow first you find and label a
memory in the brain and then you
activate it with a switch
as simple as that
are you convinced
so turns out finding a memory in the
brain isn't all that easy indeed this is
way more difficult than let's say
finding a needle in a haystack
because at least you know the needle is
still something you can physically put
your fingers on but memory is not
and also there's way more cells in your
brain than the number of straws you know
in a typical haystack
so yeah this task does seem to be
daunting but luckily we got help from
the brain itself it turned out that all
we need to do is basically to let the
brain form a memory and then the brain
will tell us which cells are involved in
that particular memory so
what was going on in my brain while i
was recalling the memory of an x if you
were to just completely ignore human
ethics for a second and slice up my
brain right now you would see that there
was an amazing number of brain regions
that were active while recalling that
memory now one brain region that would
be robustly active in particular is
called the hippocampus which for decades
has been implicated in processing the
kinds of memories that we hold near and
dear which also makes it an ideal target
to go into and to try to find and maybe
reactivate a memory when you zoom in
into the hippocampus of course you will
see lots of cells but we are able to
find which cells are involved in a
particular memory because whenever a
cell is active like when it's forming a
memory it will also leave a footprint
that will later allow us to know these
cells are recently active so the same
way that building lights at night let
you know that somebody is probably
working there at any given moment in a
very real sense there are biological
sensors within a cell that are turned on
only when that cell was just working
there's sort of biological windows that
light up to let us know that that cell
was just active
so we clipped part of the sensor and
attached that to a switch to control the
cells
and we packed this switch into an
engineered virus and inject that into
the brain of the mice
so whenever a memory isn't being formed
any active cells for that memory will
also have this switch installed so
here's what the hippocampus looks like
after forming a fear memory for example
the sea of blue that you see here are
densely packed brain cells but the green
brain cells the green brain cells are
the ones that are holding on to a
specific fear memory
so you're looking at the crystallization
of the fleeting formation of fear
you're actually looking at the
cross-section of a memory right now
now for the switch we've been talking
about ideally that switch has to act
really fast it shouldn't take minutes or
hours to work it should act at the speed
of the brain in milliseconds so
what do you think shu could we use let's
say pharmacological drugs to activate or
inactivate brain cells no
drugs are pretty messy they spread
everywhere and also it takes forever to
act on cells so it will not allow us to
control our memory in real time
so steve how about let's zap the brain
with electricity
so electricity is pretty fast but we
probably wouldn't be able to target it
to just the specific cells that hold
onto a memory and we'd probably fry the
brain oh that's true
so it looks like
we indeed we need to find a better way
to impact the brain at the speed of
light
so
it just so happens that light travels at
the speed of light
so
maybe we could activate or inactivate
memories by just using light that's
pretty fast and because normally brain
cells don't respond to pulses of light
so those that would respond to pulses of
light are those that contain a light
sensitive switch now to do that first we
need to trick brain cells to respond to
laser beams yep you heard it right we
are trying to shoot lasers into the
brain
and the technique that lets us do that
is optogenetics optogenetics gave us
this light switch that we can use to
turn brain cells on or off and the name
of that switch is channel rhodopsin seen
here as these green dots attached to
this brain cell
you could think of channel rhodopsin as
a sort of light sensitive switch that
can be artificially installed in brain
cells so that now we can use that switch
to activate or inactivate the brain cell
simply by clicking it and in this case
we click it on with pulses of light so
we attach this light sensitive switch of
channel redoxing to the sensor we've
been talking about and inject this into
the brain
so whenever a memory is being formed any
active cell for that particular memory
will also have this light sensitive
switch installed
so that we can control these cells by
the flipping of laser just like this one
you see
so let's put all of this to the test now
what we can do is we can take our mice
and then we can put them in a box that
looks exactly like this box here and
then we can give them a very mild foot
shock so that they form a fear memory of
this box they learned that something bad
happened here
now with our system the cells that are
active in the hippocampus in the making
of this memory only those cells will now
contain channel rhodopsin
when you are as small as a mouse it
feels as if the whole world is trying to
get you
so the best response of defense is
trying to be undetected
whenever a mouse is in fear it will show
this very typical behavior by staying at
one corner of the box trying to not move
any part of his body and this posture is
called freezing
so if i must remember that something bad
happened in this box and we when we put
them back into the same box it will
basically show freezing because it
doesn't want to be detected by any
potential threats in this box so you can
think of freezing as you're walking down
the street minding your own business and
then out of nowhere you almost run into
an ex-girlfriend or ex-boyfriend
and now those terrifying two seconds
where you start thinking what do i do do
i say hi do i shake their hand do i turn
around run away do i sit here pretend
like i don't exist
those kind of fleeting thoughts that
physically incapacitate you to
temporarily give you that deer and
headlights look
however if you put the mouse in a
completely different new box like
that the next one
it will not be afraid of this box
because there's no reason that it will
be afraid of this new environment
but what if we put the mouse in this new
box but at the same time we activate the
fear memory using laser just like we did
before
are we going to bring back the fear
memory for the first box into this
completely new environment all right and
here's the million dollar experiment now
to bring back to life the memory of that
day i remember that the red sox had just
won it was a green spring day perfect
for going up and down the river and then
maybe going to the north end to get some
cannolis hashtag you're saying now
shu and i on the other hand we're in a
completely windowless black room not
making any ocular movement that even
remotely resembles an eye blink because
our eyes were fixed onto a computer
screen we were looking at this mouse
here trying to activate a memory for the
first time using our technique and this
is what we saw when we first put the
mouse into this box it's exploring
sniffing around walking around minding
its own business because actually by
nature mice are pretty curious animals
they want to know what's going on in
this new box it's interesting
but the moment we we turn on laser like
you see now all of a sudden the mouse
enters this freezing mode it stays at
here and try not to move any part of its
body clearly it's freezing
so indeed looks like we're able to bring
back the fear memory for the first box
in this completely new environment
while watching this steve and i are as
shocked as mouse itself
so after the experiment the two of us
just left the room without saying
anything after kind of long awkward
period of time
steve broke the silence did that
just work
yes i said indeed it worked
we're really excited about this
and then we published our finding in the
journal of nature
ever since the publication of our work
we've been receiving numerous comments
from all over the internet maybe we can
take a look at some of those
so
the first thing that you'll notice is
that people have really strong opinions
about this kind of work now i happen to
completely agree with the optimism of
this first quote because on a scale of
zero to morgan freeman's voice it
happens to be one of the most evocative
accolades that i've heard come our way
but
as you'll see it's not the only opinion
that's out there indeed if we take a
look at the second one i think we can
all agree that it's not probably not as
positive
but this also reminds us that although
we are still working with mice it's
probably a good idea to start thinking
and discussing about the possible
ethical ramifications of memory control
now in the spirit of the third quote we
want to tell you about a recent project
that we've been working on in lab that
we've called project inception
so
we reasoned that
now that we can reactivate a memory what
if we do so but then begin to tinker
with that memory could we possibly even
turn it into a false memory
so all memory is sophisticated and
dynamic
but if just for simplicity let's imagine
memory as a movie clip
so far what we told you is basically we
can control this play button of the clip
so that we can play this video clip
anytime anywhere
but is there a possibility that we can
actually get inside the brain and edit
this movie clip so that we can make it
different from the original
yes we can
turn out that all we need to do is
basically reactivate a memory using
laser just like we did before but at the
same time if we present new information
and allow this new information to
incorporate into this old memory
this will change the memory it's not
like making a remix tape
so
how do we do this
rather than finding a fear memory in the
brain we can start by taking our animals
and let's say we put them in a blue box
like this blue box here and we find the
brain cells that represent that blue box
and we trick them to respond to pulses
of light exactly like we had said before
now the next day we can take our animals
and place them in a red box that they've
never experienced before we can shoot
light into the brain to reactivate the
memory of the blue box so what would
happen here if while the animals
recalling the memory of the blue box we
gave it a couple of mild foot shocks
so here we're trying to artificially
make an association between the memory
of the blue box and the foot shocks
themselves we're just trying to connect
the two
so to test if we have done so we can
take our animals once again and place
them back in the blue box again we had
just reactivated the memory of the blue
box while the animal got a couple of
mild foot shocks and now the animal
suddenly freezes it's as though it's
recalling being mildly shocked in this
environment even though that never
actually happened
so
it formed a false memory because it's
falsely fearing an environment where
technically speaking nothing bad
actually happened to it
so so far we're only talking about this
light control on switch
in fact we also have a light controlled
off switch
and it's very easy to imagine that by
installing this light control off switch
we can also turn off a memory anytime
anywhere
so everything we've been talking today
is based on this philosophically charted
principle of neuroscience that the mind
with its all seemingly mysterious
properties is actually made of physical
stuff that we can tinker with and for me
personally i see a world where we can
reactivate any kind of memory that we'd
like i also see a world where we can
erase unwanted memories
now i even see a world where editing
memories is something of a reality
because we're living in a time where
it's possible to pluck questions from
the tree of science fiction and to
ground them in experimental reality
nowadays people in the lab and the
people in other groups all over the
world are using similar methods to
activate or edit memories whether that's
old or new positive or negative
all sorts of memories so that we can
understand how memory works for example
one group in our lab was able to find
the brain cells that make up a fear
memory and converted them into a
pleasurable memory just like that that's
exactly what i mean about editing these
kinds of processes now one dude in lab
was even able to reactivate memories of
female mice in male mice which rumor has
it is a pleasurable experience
indeed
we are living in a very exciting moment
where science doesn't have any arbitrary
speed limits but is only bound by our
own imagination and finally what do we
make of all this how do we push this
technology forward these are the
questions that should not remain just
inside the lab
and so one goal of today's talk was to
bring everybody up to speed with the
kind of stuff that's possible in modern
neuroscience but now just as importantly
to actively engage everybody in this
conversation
so let's think together as a team about
what this all means and where we can and
should go from here because shu and i
think we all have some really big
decisions ahead of us
thank you
[Applause]